Yeah.
Well, well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Interesting.
With the ever increasing demand for
greater speed, an aircraft carrier.
Oh,
oh,
talking about,
yeah.
Yeah.
We welcome guests to,
I think I appreciate that even more
than I do too. And I, you know what?
I actually think,
by the way that is called,
that is called Canadian denim.
It's by Garrett herder.
Uh,
that's the,
I think that he actually
is the ultimate dad boner.
And here's why we can get
lost in the reaction. Go
ahead. Cause you can get lost.
You can get lost in the reactions. Right.
And think that that's really what it is.
But it's actually really about the
reaction to the whatever circumstance.
Right? And so some people are
actually reacting in huge ways,
but to truly astounding things
in other, you know, the whales
coming out of the water and
the guy's like, oh my God,
or normal reaction because
it truly is remarkable. Or,
or when the guy in the plane sees
the eclipse and he's like, Oh man,
I forget the word.
I mean he gets excited,
but that's a phenomenal
thing that he's seeing.
This guy's reacting like
this to a fucking highway.
So I think he's actually the,
the biggest dad boner of all cause.
So it's the level of Dad Boehner is
directly proportional to the stimuli.
Right. Well, so some people have
reacted even bigger than him.
Few because he sounds like he's coming,
but still it's to a highway,
you know who gets that right?
This is him. I mean it's, Oh,
the story that this road towels come on.
I mean it sounds like he's drugged.
Yeah.
Do you think it's a mental
illness? I think this guy
has something wrong with it.
Yeah, for sure. But you know, I
dunno if he's, if he's truly like,
I want to say he's mentally ill to,
to like kind of poke at them. No,
but I think this guys were really this
excited. I think it's actually genuine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh. That's him for real.
Right. We're running down
the street on the highway.
We pointed out it's very
similar to somebody.
Oh God.
Coming really,
you know?
Do you think it's because maybe he was
watching them build it for so long,
like maybe that's his route to
work every day. I think his level,
his real excitement is infrastructure.
Highways. That's his jam.
So when he sees the, the where the, the
fucking highway ends or where it needs,
whatever,
yeah.
He gets that fucking excited about
everyone's got to have something they do.
That's amazing. That's amazing. Yeah.
Um, I'm sober, I'm so excited to be here.
I spent the last 48 hours
in a courtyard Marriott.
How is that really exciting?
I mean,
it was really neat just to sit in the
brown room and then as I forget how a
boring the days are for stand
up. Yeah. I forgot about that.
Like you have to just fill hours of
time. Yeah. And I didn't do a good job.
I just sat in my room and I watch
Netflix all day and slept well.
I think maybe you did do a good job.
Maybe you're not giving it maybe. I mean,
how are you supposed to do it?
I think maybe you do,
you do a lot more on the road. You're
like, oh, I worked out. I, well,
the workouts big to be on the road, I
got to do it. I, I actually at the point,
I'm at this point now, I won't
do a show without it. Yeah.
See you're good that, that part
of it. But I mean, I do it,
I like to do it two hours before showtime.
Wow. That's when I start to sleep.
That's when I start my nap.
Really? Five o'clock. No, I,
if I have a seven o'clock,
5:00 AM in the gym this way I
can know I can work out. Um,
and I don't try to kill myself.
I try to do enough where I'm like,
I'm sweating heart rates definitely
up, but I'm not exhausted. And,
um,
and this way I feel really alert so
that then I can go back to my room.
I don't have to panic, shower, change,
get ready. And then it's like, you know,
I have 15, 20 minutes to get
to the venue. How my day went.
My Day is, I have two beds. There's
one that you sleep in. Yeah.
And the other one you eaten.
And I ordered Postmates and I ate.
I do like the separate beds
and one's for stuff like that.
Put all your shit on it. You
turn the air off, turn it down.
Now you're very suspicious. I
am. Cause I saw you're insane.
Post on Instagram where you showed
that in Sacramento this week.
You had the heat on in your room.
76 I like it. A balmy 76 God,
but that feels good to me.
It feels natural. Normal. I
don't like, I hate cold air.
We ever had a dispute in court.
They would.
They would bring that as
evidence and the divorce.
The judge would rule against you and
be like, well this is a crazy, yeah,
just the gavel come down. What about
the end of the jurors would be like,
well what about,
what about what I tolerate as a wife,
like a lot of your boxer shorts setting
and do what I did do while you were gone
and I thought about you
because nothing, the farting,
the belching,
snoring shit's the constant shifting.
You're always excusing yourself to shit.
You've been doing it much
more than I have. If you,
if you want to be honest about it.
How are we rewarding?
Every morning we're hanging
out as a family and you're
like, oh, I gotta go shit.
You always leave the shit first.
You have to shit at like seven
o'clock in the morning. No, no.
You're gone a long time. Healthy
people should quickly. Yeah, but I,
so I have to check Instagram.
I got to look at the Twitter.
I got it posted on a long, you really
are grinding them out, I guess.
It doesn't take long to come out.
My road dumps are very,
can I tell you what gave me, listen,
if you're having trouble taking a shit,
let me tell you what
will kick out your jams.
Go to Starbucks by the
instant coffee at Starbucks.
I drink those on the road instead of
the swell that they call coffee at the
courtyard Marriott and I shit like
footlong. Really? Yeah. I did.
Really proud of you. So wait,
what were you going say though?
Kind of lost me and all this.
We're talking about judges. So, um,
I uh, I like to talk more about
Starbucks. Instant coffee. In a minute.
I slept in your, in your spot. And how
was that? It was great. It was great.
And then, uh, one night,
right before I went to bed,
I sat like I sat up and I clip my toenails
in the bed and then I just brushed
him to your side of the floor. Yeah.
That's so rude. I let you do that.
Could picture you go like, oh,
like stepping on one and uh,
it's not nice and made me happy.
Let's open this show. Okay. Yeah,
we've got to do this. Here we go.
That's so rude. Hell, y'all know,
I know Kevin Cooley coming in g lab.
Maybe you think this guy's getting railed,
which a lot of people like Joe,
my dog slowly just kind of food or my
dog's going to eat this kind of food
because it caused the lower. I want to
test that out and if they get bull shit.
Hmm.
Oh is Randy? Don't bring
anyone in London. Well, well,
well go to your mom's house
Christina.
Cause it's interesting.
Okay.
Yeah, I think our son has
more teeth in this guy.
This guy doesn't have a lot of teeth,
but he's a big burly dude and um,
he's tired of people talking
about comparing a dog.
Foods are saying like, my dog doesn't
like that. Yeah. I don't think it's that,
that's not true. Like my debt, my
dog doesn't like, I think people,
I think that does happen. Yeah. Dogs,
I've always just eaten whatever
slop we put in their bowl. Like you,
it's similar to how you are.
That's probably true.
But I think some people do our
big end of that saying like,
oh my dog is a big fan
of this and I guess yeah,
dog won't eat that or doesn't like them.
Now he's got a number eight on this
knuckle Auger to more aids to see a hail
Hitler. The eight, eight,
eight that's what the white
supremacists, yeah. Let's see.
Ape Letter of the alphabet.
Remember we learned this blue man
taught us this blue band Tati yeah,
cause there was somebody with an
eight, eight, eight tattoo and he,
this is when he was in studio and
he's like eight is h. Oh right.
It's the eighth letter of the alphabet.
Will do. We know our abcs. Hail Hitler.
Let's try it. A, B, c, d, e.
F. G. H.
I don't know if he has all three. That'd
be really disturbing if he did. Well,
I mean I,
if the shoe fits,
he sounds like someone
then say hi to Hitler.
He sounds like the kind of
guy that would have, yeah.
Well I don't know if that's fair
to people that sound like that.
There's a lot of people who
sound like they numbed. Dang man.
Hey Hitler. See Danny at Danny.
He's not from the south. No,
she says it totally differently to
kind of sleepy. Yeah, I got
him some Maddie Dell food.
Some kind of body is cheaper.
Can Mighty dog.
Oh, I wouldn't eat mighty dog. At least I
out of the clip. I had
no, we were going there.
Oh my God. He fucking woo. Boy.
Is it done? I think I
can't even do this
for a second cause he's making a video.
Woo.
Why
is this funny? First of all, I
didn't, sometimes I look at clips.
I have no idea this was coming.
I swear to you. I had no idea.
You said you've seen,
right?
I've seen the beginning
wait kind of dog food.
I tried.
That's FIEPs prescription.
That's how you not vomit the
science hill diet or whatever.
Cause he's got that
guy that worked at the,
at the dog food place said don't
eat that cause he said it had a,
it's got maggots and stuff,
but then you got a nice ring.
I did get my got a nice ring.
It didn't taste that bad.
I don't know what this fucking
hillbillies all crying about.
But you think he'd be used to eating
like raccoon and snake and and be
squirreled. Be Fun to hang out
with. What does it say on the,
on this tattoo here you read
it. It's tough. It's that.
Oh it's Stewie isn't, that's two weeks
from the family guy. I don't think it is.
It's really weird. Oh yeah, you're
writing. Maybe it's his catch phrase.
I don't know what it is. Look,
at least I did it for a ring.
This guy did it just for the,
he just did it for like youtube likes.
Well that was a very entertaining video.
I would tell him that that was very
entertaining. It's not that bad.
What's this fucking sissy crying about?
Can Pussy you hit the road and
you're hitting the road again?
I'm going to Fart next this week and then
I've been single dad. I was doing that.
I left you alone for exactly 48 hours
and now you're a full single dad.
Single Dad,
48 hours.
What happened while I was gone? Uh, we
had a good time actually. It's really,
it's fun, right? Yeah.
Sometimes it's good.
Obviously really trying
moments and yeah, and the, uh,
I think the thing that wears on you
that wears on nerves is when the whining
doesn't stop. When you hear like,
do you want this? You want that?
Do you want the other thing? Like when
you, when you offer everything up,
you don't rest. Do you want change? Do
you want food? And they're like, ah.
And that goes on and on. That's when
you're like, I'm all right. Yeah.
Is anyone else coming over to help or not?
Yeah.
So I understand that it's hard cause he's,
he only knows a few words.
So what do you want? And then sometimes
they don't know what they want.
That's the other thing.
They just want you to fix it.
But sometimes they're tired, but
you don't, you think that, oh,
do you want to sleep?
And they do,
but they don't know that they
need to work to get to sleep shit.
Like they don't know how to,
yeah, it's tough. It wears on you.
But there's a lot of fun moments.
He's the cutest fucking little kid.
So I had a lot of fun with him.
You know,
the only times I get stressed out
or like, excuse me, nighttime,
like if he doesn't sleep through the
night and then I'm up with him all night
and then I have to be with them the
next day alone, then I'm like, oh,
I want to blow my brains out.
Yeah, there's, it's tough.
It's whatever. But the good news
is that you've got a lot of, uh,
check attention at the mall.
A lot of Cherokee country club.
I've got to tell you something.
It's so funny. It's interesting.
I take him to the country club and
you know,
for people that don't know it
here, out here, if you're like,
why are you keep going on the mall?
For us it's like we live in
a very hot city and it's,
the heat has already begun. It's
like in the 90s, like today it's 93.
Um, is that, let me check my apple
watch to confirm that it was in the car.
So they said in the car,
but anyways,
and then the other day over the
weekend it was really windy,
like trees blew down.
Um,
so that is one of the reasons we go and
it's like, it's, you know, it's space.
It's, it's uh, he can,
he can run stuff for kids to go get lunch.
So anyways,
we go there and I notice that I'm getting
a lot of different types of looks.
I'm getting like dudes that are like,
like let's say three guys are having
coffee together at a place looking at me
like she, that guy like that,
that's what the look is look,
just like you see that guy with the
baby, the kidnapper, the kidnapper.
Or like as like a woman,
you know,
that's how I read their look.
And I noticed that it's a different look.
Like they don't register a guy with
a three or a five year old like that.
It's up and running and, but when it's
a like our kids 16 months they're like,
Huh. Women too would look at me
curiously like, cause I'm sitting there,
you know,
I'm putting him back in the stroller
because he gets tired of running and I'm
pulling up a part of banana giving a
pieces of banana, here's your water.
Like I'm doing all that caretaking thing.
And they're looking at me like,
yeah, where did this guy steal this? His
mom, mom does everything like no offense,
but mom is really,
I get it.
But she has an interesting real look to
get from strangers and it tells you a
lot. It tells you a lot about, you know,
it was so society and
also these individuals.
I mean some of them are looking at
me because they think that I even,
I shouldn't even be doing that.
Well,
and that's the thing is that people
assume women are natural caregivers. Yeah.
And that's really not
true because you have to,
I had to learn how to
take care of an infant.
It's not like it comes out of you and
you're like, oh, I know how to breastfeed.
Like right. No, I, someone had to
come to our house and teach me how,
and then I had to learn
how to change a diaper.
So it's learned behavior
and men can learn it too.
And I don't know why the fuck the
default his mom all the time on every,
well, I know why it makes sense
actually. It came out of me, which, yeah,
because as a woman,
and also don't forget your,
the actual food source and
I'm talking to you about,
but from the beginning the
woman is the food source.
So it makes sense because we're programmed
biologically for you to have the,
the life grows in you and then you nurture
it. So it's not that crazy. But it's,
it's interesting that you know,
obviously people in times of evolved
and people are looking at me like,
what the fuck are you doing?
I mean, he stole baby. Yeah.
They looked at me like I was
crazy and I could, you know,
I wasn't like one or two people.
I'm talking about multiple people
throughout this hour at a mall.
We're looking at me like, what are you
doing? I know it's sad when people,
when men are like, I'm going to babysit
and babysitting my children this weekend.
When my wife goes away. It's like,
you're not babysitting assholes.
Those are your kids.
Why is that the assumption that
only mom can take care of children?
I think men should be offended that it's
assumed to be a female role. I mean,
don't you get some satisfaction in taking
care of Ellis? I of course, like I said,
is factual, so yeah. No, it's great. I
mean like I know I'm doing a woman's work,
but I still, I still enjoy it. Just like
if you were to fucking build a deck,
you'd be like, oh, this is cool
as well. Just what humans can do.
I feel like people can do it. I
don't know, despite having to like,
like if I cook, I'm like, oh cool. Like
chicks do this, you know, you cooked,
he cooked excellent. I did have
a great Sunday cooking day. Wait,
what was it called? The brisket
and is that what you mean? No,
I did try to dictate. That was so good.
Tip was God damn, that was amazing.
I got a big green egg.
There's some, uh, another,
some super barbecue fans out there.
Um, I like to work with fire,
so I'm, I don't like doing, I like
charcoal. I like wood chips and I like,
I like messing with fire.
And this thing
is, uh, it's really,
it's really simple actually because you
control your heat just based on the air
you let into it. So you can, you can
basically get this thing if you want to,
let's say throw a steak on and you
want to just have that thing go quick,
you can make,
you can make the thing about almost
700 degrees and just have the vents
completely open, put your penis. And it's
like a fucking, you know, almost like a,
like a broiler and then boom, you're
seg has done in a minute, you know,
but you can also reduce the air flow and
bring that temperature in that to 25 to
50 range and slow cook some things kind
of. And that's what I did with that.
It was so,
but you see it's smokey tasting
because you get smoky smoke. Yeah.
You can't like smoke a cake in there. You
can, you can smoke a cake. Absolutely.
You missed it while,
uh, while you were gone.
I did a couple of birthday cakes in there.
Yeah.
Some cupcakes like smoking chocolate.
People love that. That natural
cold tasting cake is like,
it's, it's just such a, it's a,
it's an uh, it's on a common, but
it's a, it's really rewarding.
Yeah. Interesting. No,
but I actually did do a
British baking show treat.
I tried it.
That was awesome. Yeah. Cause we
found, uh, the secondary show,
the masterclass,
they have it on Netflix and you can
watch Mary Berry [inaudible] and Paul
Hollywood make the recipes Hollywood.
And you know what I,
what I noticed when I was watching it is
that Paul Hollywood is like a big show
off. Yeah. Like he cracks the eggs
with one hand on the side of the bell.
He does it fast too. Right? Like showing
off. Yeah. And he does everything really,
really fast to show off.
And Mary Berry was like, Oh,
I've noticed when you crack it that way,
all the egg drips on the side
of the bowl and he, you know,
she was kind of like relaxed
83 Douche bag, take it,
take it down a notch.
But that's the, that's it
kind of contributes to the
chemistry of them. Right.
Because she's like, TD, notice none
of the egg drivels all my bone.
And he's like, that's fine. They're
like, it doesn't even, he's like, yeah,
it's just like you are
with your mom basically.
Yeah. Okay. Mom.
He made a couple of old jokes at her at
one point and she did not react like a
couple of them. She was like,
nope, she did not like it.
So I tried his chocolate volcano.
Yeah. Missed one small but key step. Yeah,
I forgot the two tablespoons of flour.
God dammit.
And I could just see him trying it
and being like the flavors there.
Yeah. It's a good bike. It's a good
book. Yeah. Do you didn't get to rise.
You should have gotten your right.
Let me just get that, that molten
lava cake grise for those of you like,
Oh, you guys are back on
the fat train. We literally,
we did it like bakers. We had a
couple bites. I fucking throw it away.
I made fitness today.
I reign it in. Yeah, we're go. All good.
Got To make fitness and make
it all the time. I made it.
I made it four times last week and a,
I'll make fitness each morning.
I'm going to do,
uh,
I do twice with a trainer and I'm
going to do a couple solos this week.
Can I attorney into like that
mom life that I got going?
You just pull out these twice a
week taking care of the kid alone.
Now I'm pretty exciting.
Yeah, it was pretty exciting.
Now there's one thing that, you
know, we've got a lot of emails,
things that go through.
One thing that has been coming up
is like personality wise. Okay.
Really is, um, the champ.
You're not going to read
listener emails are you?
Because those are always really slanted
towards one of us or they don't really
know us in real life. You say
I got one better for you. Okay.
I have actual commentary.
I was listening to this
podcast contest personality.
And if for me it's to,
even if it's not a concert,
it's like five by five by five.
You have to go cause peanut
has it really nicely.
[inaudible] mark [inaudible]
charming,
amazing [inaudible]
and all the things around you.
When that,
wait a minute is that it's
not gone through there. You're
the winner now. Yeah. Hi.
But wait a minute, that's not some
random color. That's your biological mom.
That's the woman that raised you.
How about somebody that knows us both.
She's supposed to feel that about
the people that knows both. You know,
I mean there's other people that know.
That's your mom.
Sadie loans. Hey, uh, I was
just listening to them. Awesome.
Uh, you know, I love
Christine. I don't know
what
years Ryan Sickler, you know,
I know, I know who this is.
Beautiful girl, great mom,
hilarious comedian. Yeah.
Um, great friend, great daughter.
But when it comes to personality,
cardboard,
absolute, just dry shift sandpaper,
you know what I mean? Yup.
Really nothing there.
Definitely married off. I mean,
when it comes to personality stuff,
you'd definitely have a better person.
I can't believe you solicited advice.
That was Ryan sickler of the crab feast
podcast. Yup. He's a what? A trader.
I can't believe it. There's different,
I mean, people are calling in.
Those are people, those are too
biased. People that you set up.
Hey Buddy, listen to the
show. Interesting question.
Who has the best personality?
I think that part,
Christina,
clearly the more intelligent
educational background. He's so into
that. I think in terms of personality,
after all, you know, my son. Oh
yeah. Awesome. You got listen,
most of your personality from me.
Yeah.
So I think that my vote has to go to here.
Unreal.
I mean it's obviously a skewed,
I don't know.
I mean there's people, I mean
obviously my parents are going to vote.
Hey Tom, it's mouthful
shrine. Oh, we'll charge. Uh,
I was thinking about this lately.
I don't know why I was thinking about it.
You're worth pursuing is so
funny. On stage. On stage,
but off stage,
um,
I kind of think you have a better
personality. You're fun to hang out with.
You always got the joke.
Yup. Like offstage.
I like hanging out with you,
man. You should know. Yeah,
please don't tell Christina I said that.
Wow. Wow. This is really quite
a coup here. Well, so I mean,
I'm devastated. I can't believe
it. It is kind of alarming
not to go off.
Go to [inaudible] Park test.
I told them about what
you said up the other day.
You take it, I'm a guy, my
personality, I'm not on anybody's list.
So talk to take you say that you do
have a high rise supposed to now.
You know what? I'm sorry. Yeah. She's a
great mom. Go look in Prague. Funny Comic.
Of course he's kind of like,
ah, you know what I'm saying?
They got the Goulash and a sword.
They're jumping up a salary. Shit.
Your personalities kind of smooth.
Uh,
Christine here she goes back.
There you go.
Wow. Thank you. For what? It's worth
straight black. So do you feel like, I
can't believe this. I know it's kind of,
it is crazy.
But you feel like this is because these
are all people that are more connected
to me.
Is that what you're saying?
I'm saying I just have a feeling
that you solicited these comments.
These are just people that called him
and said these things. I, you know,
so weird that they,
the everyone,
all of our friends are listening to our
Pi gas and then felt compelled to call
and leave a voicemail that,
I mean, but how do you, do you
think like, do you think if you had,
if we had your people call in it
would be different though or no,
you think so?
Tell me what you did.
It's a Shauna,
I heard there was like a discussion
about who's the personality fam.
No died when, I mean I've known
Christina since I was 16 yeah,
and I love her for her personality.
She's Robert took gust,
but then when I met Tom, I mean when
they got married I was like, wow,
this guy has got a great personality.
Say Personality Champ, Tom Cigarettes.
That's your best. That's terrible. Your
best. I can't believe you did that to her.
How much did you pay her pay or
anything? You did? I did not.
I'm going to find out how much you paid
her to say they are a dime. Oh my God.
You called. I know you did. You sent them
glass and tee shirts for free. No, I did.
You sent her and her husband Jimmy free
tee shirts and that's why they did that.
I got that. I know I did not. No, I
know what I think it's pretty much,
it feels settled to me. These are
the people that know us. Both.
Even the listeners obviously side more
towards me. Yeah, no, it's the way.
Everybody who commented Nosa everybody
knows us. That's interesting.
They're voting. They're voting
with their voices, baby. Okay.
So I think it's the assignment.
Throw in the towel on this one only
tells me you've manipulated the data.
I listen to Steve Call and I'm just
looking at the podcast and one of the time
there and my buddy Steve,
I must say when it comes to looks,
Christina is by far the much better
looking person. That's obvious. Yeah.
No contest at all. On
the same day. However,
personality wise I got to give it to Tom.
Yeah, this is too fast. Or you go,
this is so stupid. How has it stupid?
I mean it's so obviously manipulated,
not manipulated. This is,
these are alternative facts. Everybody
knows. No, it's not that. It's so stupid.
Don't you feel done with it now?
No, I don't feel done. In fact,
this compels me to continue
the dialogue and uh,
I'm going to take it to the
streets and I'm going to really,
really interview people
from now on. Really? Yeah.
Do you really think that anybody
would side with you? Yes.
Everybody who knows us.
Both unbiased people.
Maybe not family members or best
friends that you've manipulated? Yeah.
Well, it seems like one of
yours, um, sided with me.
One of your best friends, you paid her
in free tee shirt today. Not Today. Her,
you paid her in Fiji. She, I,
she sent me a picture in our glass
and shirts last night and I thought,
well that's weird. That's odd. No,
she doesn't normally, you know, buy,
merge from us and then now
it makes perfect sense.
You send her those shirts and you bribed
her. That was pretty great though.
Do you I know the funniest thing, I can't
believe you did this. This is too funny.
Oh you are.
So
no, no. Down in a two carbon
compound reacts with a four
carbon compound that you
produced a six carbon compounds,
citric acid and only fuck.
In subsequent reactions,
two carbons are lost to see
o two electrons are stored
and ATP is produced. God dammit. No,
I never even took chemistry because I
couldn't get past the first like week of
it. I did. And the guy fucking loved
me and that's why he gave me a deed.
He loves me. That shit so
hard. He didn't love you.
He probably loved how hot you
were in high school pen. No,
he was at Father So-and-so. I was somebody
that treated him like a human being.
Yeah. You know, like,
like I treated the teacher like a person
I had real conversation with and you
could tell that nobody did that.
So he was so engaged with
me and I really, this, it's,
this is like an extension of my
awesome personality, but he was like,
some might say a manipulative personality.
He loved me.
And I remember he could not get
over how bad I was at chemistry.
And he did it in a subtle way.
He wasn't obvious, but he,
you could see it on his face like,
don't you get this? And I'm like, no,
I could not get it. Get it saved my
life. I mean, in high school I could not,
I had to drop out and take two
different classes to count as chemistry,
if that's what you had to do in order to,
I dunno,
be of value in this world. Oh my God.
It'd be a fucking bottom feeder. I mean,
it would just be, I'd be living in a
cardboard box in a gutter. Bangladesh.
Why's it gotta be the dirtiest place?
I know that is not the dirtiest
place on earth. Why do you say that?
Because I've seen photos.
You're horrible.
Where do you think this is a
display of your personality?
Where do you think the worst place on
earth is? Be? Real and obviously to Lido.
How dare you? The PARISBURG
Uri. I've not been to Erie.
Um, no, I dunno. I Dunno where
the worst, I mean on on earth.
Your say nothing's that bad in the US.
I think Bangladesh.
I mean, no, I, I wouldn't have said
Bangladesh. Pakistan, I've been there.
It's terrible. It's not as bad as you
know. It's funny. When I was in Hong Kong,
which is amazing, a lot of native
people, they were telling me,
don't go to mainland China.
Seriously?
No, no, that seriously. They're like,
don't go outside of the cities of China
yet outside of it, they were like,
I've heard that too. Rough. It's real.
These were Chinese people telling me this.
They're like, they thought they
thought we were going there.
If you guys go into Shanghai and stuff,
we were like, no. And they're like, well,
don't, you know, don't
venture outside of there.
I've heard there's a lot
of like toothless people,
people with five legs and two heads.
You know who heads I see that a
lot on the, and the Instagram.
Like I fall on Nat Geo on Instagram
and they're, and they're like,
this baby was born with five
legs and two heads from India.
It's never America. That
the five legged baby. Yeah.
I'm really,
I'm really amused by your quote.
Consensus of this got the better
personality. That's very, it's very done.
Very amusing. Uh, do you wanna hear the
funniest part of this whole thing though?
So
when I called and I told my parents
to call in, I go, so here's like,
to manipulate the data,
here's the set up and do it.
So my dad calls and he acts like a,
he's just a regular caller.
So I had to have him call
twice because the first time,
hilarious as if the listeners would not
know who he is. So he first time he goes
on who the personality
and winter,
so, and he can't, he can't say it right
either person. Personality. Winter. Yeah.
And he goes, Hey Tom. So I called back
and I go, what was that? And he goes, oh,
your mom said to so that the
people don't know. It's uh,
it's me like to the, we don't, I go,
do you guys don't think that that
not only would the listeners know,
but that like we wouldn't play. It'd
be like, Oh, that's your dad. Yeah.
You can hide who that is. And
he goes, yeah, I thought so.
But he just left it as I'm dead.
Hey Tom,
just want to offer my opinion.
I go, you've never called
me. Never. Not even one time.
I've never heard him calling you that.
It's always a buddy buddy, buddy. Yeah.
Big Dog. Yeah. Never time. No.
The funny part too actually is that our
interior designer was here this morning
showing us plans and you weighed in.
She weighed in and were
really good relationship with
her. She's very funny. And,
and I go, forgive Tom. He's, he's late.
He's just not very good personality.
And I go and I go Shauna,
that's her name. To what?
Who Do you think has a better
personality? Tom Or me? Yeah,
and at first she gave the very
considerate like, well you guys are both.
And I was, when she broke it down,
come on and here's what she said.
She thinks I am a,
I have a better personality.
Show more people. She said, she
said you're kinder to more people.
That doesn't make better movies are
more selective of who you are kind to.
In other words, you withdraw
and restrict being kind. Yeah.
Selectively.
Yes.
Whereas I am that way with more people.
Jeez.
I wonder which of the two of us
as a better personnel, hold on.
Yana allow me to defend.
Here's why. A, I'm a woman.
If I walk around being all googly star
ride and kind every a whole out there,
guys think you're hitting on
them if you're nice to them.
And I had to learn that in my twenties
I think you learned it this weekend too.
And I did. Yeah. I got hit on
actually twice in the airport.
My wedding ring is not big enough.
Yeah.
So the second part to that is I grew
up in a major city with a lot of, hi,
how are you? What's your name? What's
Your Pronoun? Is that what happened?
The second part is that
when you grow up in La,
there's a lot of nut bags here
that come from other places.
So you got to put up the shield
first and then, then if you're cool,
they're all nice now. But I'm
nice to servers. I'm nice to,
to everybody. I just don't go out of
my way to be kind. Kind of like, hey,
be my friend. Yeah. Not
until I know you. Okay. No,
I'm not rude to like service people
though. Never said you were rude to say,
but that's what I'm saying. Like I would
never ever be shitty to like service.
You're obviously not very kind
to the Bangladeshi people. Oh,
they're not listening. They
don't. We don't think so.
They don't have I phones like aren't they
don't, oh, podcast. I'm just kidding. No,
I know they did. No, they
don't. They're no, no, no.
Like Yoshi. No, they don't know by the
way. Oh, I gotta make this announcement.
So the live Yoshi episode went up.
Uh,
I saw some complaints about the audio.
Luckily we got an email from a guy named
Malcolm in Seattle who volunteered an
idea to fix it.
Yeah.
And a blue band did it and it
was a thousand percent improved.
So if you tried listening and you, and
you go like, I don't like this audio,
this sucks, and you stopped,
please give it another shot.
Here's what you have to do though.
Um,
this is what I've been told
is that if you downloaded it,
you have to delete it and
download a second time because
the feed has a new file
in it. So that's a, it's the live
episode. It went up on Friday.
Um, Yoshi joined us and it
was, he's crazier and shit.
Crazier than, and great guests.
Great. Great. Gus? No. Back
to this Bangladeshi thing.
Just so you know, I had an Indian
stepfather for 17. Oh, I'm allowed.
I have a black friend that's one of those
lines, not the same. And he hated India.
He only ever told me horror
stories about growing up in Bombay,
Mumbai. Horrible, horrible me, mommy.
So all I ever heard was what a dump
India was and how much better America is.
And so just seeing, you know, I've
got a fucking witness. Oh, I'm not,
I'm not in the stance. That's fine
if your mom's phone, but really,
where do you think the worst place
on earth list? Let's, let's go.
It's a really great question.
I mean,
I think the worst place on
earth is hot India. Go ahead.
There's one for India yet.
Dirty check too.
And uh, undeniably. Really Poor d
check three. Yeah, three for three.
It could be like that. Yeah, it could be.
That could be the place. I don't know.
It sounds terrible. I probably a lot of
central African places. Oh boy. Oh boy.
That's gotta be rough to fuck.
Yeah. Or war torn w clearly Congo.
Oh shit man. Yeah. No,
it's got to be the worst because we're
talking about reality. Like real,
like you go there now, right? Yeah.
Shit's real right now. Terrible. Yeah.
Like you're drinking the water that
everyone's bathing in kind of stuff.
And then, yeah, aside of all,
like we take away the, the, the,
just the punishing heat.
Yeah.
The unfair extreme poverty.
The, the, the disease. The filth. Yeah.
Will you take away all
that and then, and, and,
and bullets flying overhead and
let's say you get away from all that,
you could still turn around and
have a rhino bite you and half true.
This isn't an Africa in certain parts of
Africa. Sure. Tigers can swim and, and,
and Maleo. Yeah. That's more of an India
problem. That's an India problem. Yeah.
I thought it was an Africa
thing. Yeah. Also the civility.
I've heard stories where um, a
pedestrian will be hit in the road. Yeah.
In India somewhere and they'll just
keep driving over them like people don't
pull over.
Well that's also has to do with
populations of human life is not valued as
island. Yeah. Yeah.
Once you get, once you have a
country with over 1 billion people,
imagine if we had vague right now we
had four times as many as we have right
now.
In
the states. You would, they would
report things. You'd report it. Murders,
last year report. That's less. Yeah.
You'd be like, look, it's a lot of people.
If people are fucked up,
people die. That's how you be.
You won't even have to tell
somebody if you hit a pedestrian.
Now let's keep driving SCO, which fine.
Oh, the guy. Yeah, that guy's done.
What I noticed too when I was
like in the Middle East, um,
is that people just walk on the freeway.
Yeah. There's a lot of that too.
Like camels just run next to the freeway.
People walk when they're not,
they shouldn't lock. Yeah. These,
they don't give a fuck. Yeah.
We're going to get some emails next week,
so I'm sure once you tell people you
got a lot of stuff coming up. I do.
I'm excited.
Bring it up to take my hour special.
So I'm running it now. Please
come see it. Is that loud enough?
I mean, May 4th and fifth fart. Next,
Arizona at standup arrive May 19th
through 20th June dork Teddy's at Gotham.
Come on you club June one through
three Denver [inaudible] hangover.
Denver comedy works the downtown location.
June 16th and 17th,
man friend disco at the
punchline. Comedy crab. Oh,
and I just added June 22nd.
I'm going to run it one last time here
at flip hairs in Burbank and the you who
room June 22nd.
So come check that it's the flappers
room as the shit. I love that.
I love small rooms. Yeah, I
know you're not supposed to,
but I always prefer them that said, Jean,
I'm going to be, uh, going back to Oregon
to the great state of Oregon, Oregon,
Oregon, uh, new genes.
Horrigan blue jeans,
Oregon jeans.
I like that one by the way.
We added a show May 12th
and Eugene go ducks.
Um,
so Ryan sickler is coming with me.
You'll be on both of the shows on the
12th and Eugene sickle cell sickle cells
and then the 13th we go back to Portland,
Oregon.
And the reason I did that was because
the first two I did sold out really far
ahead of time. So we're
doing two more. Uh,
on May 13th get your tickets.
The early show sold out,
but there are tickets
available to the late show.
I believe that's at 10 30 on May 13th.
Then I go to tucks in Arizona.
Uh,
[inaudible] no Nevada Reno seem a neck.
Ula, California to Django, Macula, Macula.
That's June 11th as the Pachangas.
And then I go to the dirty,
dirty. I go to Richmond, vagina,
Vagina,
Vagina Beach,
Virginia genes borough North Carolina
cheats that the cone Denim Entertainment
Center. Oh God. And
I know you did
that on purpose right? Course you
requested that venue. Um, July 14th,
Asheville, North Carolina Asheville
is Asheville. Got It. Yeah.
And July 15th, I don't know what
to call Charleston, South Carolina.
Uh, Charles Stink. Charles Stink, I dunno.
10 this 27 Tampon Beach, New
Hampshire. Hamp tamped Hampton Tampon.
Uh, Wilmington, Delaware.
I don't know what that is. A
Balton whores, Maryland on July 29,
Jesus calls and horse. Yeah.
And then, um, I go to mum,
Australia and that's
all@thomsongretta.com slash tour.
Of course we do the podcast
lives one show only August 23rd.
It's a long ways away,
but it is, it is moving.
And that is in Wes Bald Beach, Florida
at the, at the Improv and Palm Beach.
So make sure you get your tickets now.
You were starting that ass Stretton
that ass at the airport. How dare you.
And guys were like, hey. And you were
like, Hey, no, I wasn't like, Hey,
what happened was I'm wearing, I
don't wear a big chunky garish. Yeah.
Diamond Ring. I just went, didn't work.
I have a very tender little wedding band
that says Mrs [inaudible] I love this
thing. Yeah, it's cool.
It's subtle and I don't think
it stands out enough because um,
twice I got kind of like toss with
how does it work? Cause I imagine,
I'll just tell you, I imagine that, that,
that happens to you in
my mind all the time.
The guys I know how guys operate, they
see attractive woman. You just go, hey.
Right. Yup. Well, I'll tell
you what's a really big cock.
Shrinker is a one year old in
your arm. Well, I know when, uh,
I'm assuming when I'm talking about
when you're not with no child, um,
I usually look like hell when I travel
and this time I had gone to Alan,
I got my hair done and it was,
it was blown out nicely. Yeah.
So I think like I was not made up,
but I looked like a civilized human,
but I don't send out any kind of
signal, like eyes down, eyes forward.
Usually earbuds, very shut off. Like
I'm very cold in public. That is true.
Like I don't,
I'm not kind as you say to everybody.
So I'm in the security line and that's
the first guy who's about my age,
you know, he's alone and he's doing
the whole, who has Burbank airport.
It's really easy, Huh?
And I'm like, yeah, yeah.
Oh this is so much better than
Texas. And we, where are you going?
Like doing the whole,
the chatty Cathy.
Oh yeah.
To you now.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. I was
like, what husband? What kid?
And I hid the screen photo. I have you
and Ellis like immediately I changed it.
Yeah. Yeah, I changed it. Um, and then
I, you know, I'm, I shut it down though.
I don't really want to get into it.
And then I was on south airline and we
were lining up like animals and the guy
behind me did an where are you going?
A business or pleasure.
How long are you staying in Sacramento?
How do you handle it? Well, in California,
first of all, we don't do that. Like
that's a south, a southern thing.
Maybe I'm not an la, nobody talks to
people and now it's just forbidden.
It's against the rules,
you know? Okay. So I don't,
what I do is I answer politely,
but tersely I don't give a lot of details.
And by the way, I don't like people
knowing where I live, where I'm going.
I don't like fuck you.
Don't ask me.
I fucking lie to people all the time.
Now the driver, um, who do, I mean,
the airport yesterday didn't, he's like,
so are you here for business or pleasure?
And I was this close to lying and being
like, oh business, I'm a paralegal.
And then just glasses. And he
looked at the sheet and he goes, Oh,
you're a comedian. And I was just
the punchline, arrange the ride.
And I was two seconds away from just line
this guy so that I don't have to talk
about comedy for the next hour.
So I'm glad I didn't lie
to him cause I normally do.
And he did the whole thing where he,
he looked in the rear view mirror as he
was driving forward the whole fucking
time, which should me, I panicked
like, Bro, look at the road. Don't,
I don't need to make eye contact with you.
You know there's one worse than that.
And that is the full
turnaround. Yeah. Stop that.
Yeah. This isn't a movie like you're
really driving. How long you in town for
a couple of it. Look at that.
What's that there? Oh, the road.
You fucking idiot. Yeah. So do you
like to you to kind of flirt back?
I'm telling you, this whole not
kind of thing is I'm polite,
but I certainly don't invite a dialogue.
I don't really like all over my face.
That too.
I don't like small talk.
I really can't tolerate a lot of like
where are you from? What's that like?
Please can we talk about, let's talk
about anything else. I hate small talk.
I can't do it. Fuck, I can't and I can't
be polite. I can't answer things. Right.
You know? Right. You ever been hit on a,
when you were with Ellis live girls,
blue eyes.
Usually what they do is they're like,
oh my gosh. As they're looking at him,
you know, you look up at me
and they must be mom. Yeah.
There you supposed to be with this boy.
I'm telling you.
You mean to tell me that after shows now,
cause I hear stories from male comics
who are like, dude, I had a fucking,
my set was so killer. I had a four
way afterwards. I swear to God,
like there's never been a set and
then some fucking whore afterwards.
It's like you want to sext and you're
like, yeah, give me your number.
I love sexting. No, no, it doesn't
work. Right. No woman's ever been like,
you know,
I heard you talking about farts up there.
I was wondering if you would fight in my
mouth and my face. That happens. Yeah,
that happens. No they, they, they don't
really, it doesn't really work like that.
A R t
they um,
how does girls don't come solo to my
shows and they don't come in twos and
threes and we don't get like some guys
like three girls might go see this guy.
They like, it doesn't work like
that for me. It's not that for me.
Most of my audience, yeah. Cook would
have like a gaggle of girls. Absolutely.
And there's a bunch,
there's guys out there now and I'm
sure draw women like single guy.
But for me,
I'm telling you,
this happens every show guys are bringing
their girls like a guy's doing a lot
of dates, right? And that guy
takes his girl to the movies take.
And then in the meet and greet lines,
that guy will take a picture. And
this happens. Every show goes baby.
And she goes, I'm good. And then I go
and then he's like, no, no, come on.
She says I'm fine. No
thanks. No thanks for like,
I don't want a photo of this.
So you think that your onstage persona,
your personality,
so unlikable pretty much onstage?
Yes. Yeah, I think so. Yeah. Yeah.
I have, I have it all the
time. And no girls do not go
like, hey, it doesn't have,
no, never. Not even like sometimes no.
Sometimes there's jokes like they,
they will listen to our show
and they'll kick your ass.
Like there was a whole time, where
was the whole time of that, you know,
we're offering to take something
every time. Very exciting to hear.
Very exciting to hear. I was
always pleased to hear it, but,
but on a regular basis, no,
I don't get like, hey you,
sometimes groups will say like,
where are you going afterwards? Um,
and won't get hints that I don't
want to hang out. We're not social.
I'll be like, I dunno. And then they go,
oh, do you want us to wait here? And I go,
no, I don't know how long I'll
be here. And they're like,
okay, we can wait outside.
I'm like, don't do that. And then
it's like, there's still be like,
so there's a bar across the street. Yeah.
Which one is that? And then I'll be like,
yeah, yeah, I might go there. No, of
course not. I don't like to hang out.
Well, it's so late. By the
time I was done with my shows,
it was like 1230 and the audience is
tired. I'm tired. I want to go home.
I was thinking about it.
I think I told you, uh,
Burt posted some photo on his Instagram,
him with the Bachelorette group.
I think he was carrying one of them.
It was like here was tonight
and I almost texted him like,
your idea of a fun night is
my idea of a panic attack.
Like that is anxiety
inducing hundred percent like
partying with a fucking group of people
and that for him that's a show cannot
fucking do it.
Can I say what?
What gives me the most diarrhea
about an exchange like that?
The amount of small talk that
would have to ensue. Yeah.
So what's it like being a comedian?
What's it like being too,
I'm not really a big
drinker, you know? Yeah.
I would have to get fucked up to hang
out like that because bachelorettes with
anyone. With any group I'm saying because,
because of the small talk. Yeah. He says,
I can't do it sober. I'd be like, well,
I'll just fucking knocked back some
shots and do this. I'm so uncomfortable.
And in large groups too,
I have never functioned with large
groups of girlfriends or the parties.
I don't, I never, I never had a fun, it's,
I'm better like in a smaller situation.
Um,
like let's actually talk. Of
course. Yeah. I also wanted to,
Burt likes to hold court, you
know, I can't do, nothing.
Makes me more uncomfortable than that.
And he's also good. Can't do that.
Let's do this and do that.
And now it's like he has all these
ideas of how the fund can continue.
And I will say though that our audience
is so wonderful in that like every time
I work somewhere, the staff goes, God,
you have the best crowds. You guys,
you guys get to now also because
our crowds at live shows,
so responsive mix podcast
listeners and stand up fans. Right.
But I feel like the reason I keep
getting compliments from venues on the
audience is because of podcasts.
Absolutely. Because I get it.
I got it on this whole tour.
Everywhere I go, they go,
you bring in the most amazing people.
And at first I'm like,
oh you just mean like, cause they
laughed at the sh like they like a show.
He's like, no, they're like
so respectful. Oh yeah.
If it's a heckle, they they
tip well they're, they're,
they're nice. They didn't, you
know, start any shit with anyone.
They're just like good people.
So they're the best.
And I would say that they're the type of
people I actually probably would have a
drink with like one on one. Generally when
I meet Mommy's I'm like, oh thank you.
Actually a normal human being can be
friends with you. It's kind of weird,
but then I wouldn't because the anxiety
of the social interactions too much. Oh,
you got an email about that,
by the way.
I swear I go away.
We've talked about this one.
Go Away for two days and
it's like a fortress.
You've just built up all this ammo against
me. I know this is not against you.
It says it actually
says to the two of you,
but then they kind of single you out
because I've been a mommy's it's way back,
so no disrespect,
but you guys see the two of you,
but it's not about you really fired up.
They got real fired up against me.
Sounds so dumb. Low and lose when
you talk about retarded people.
I'm working on my degree
in teaching Special Ed work
at a center for adults with
intellectual disabilities,
and my kid has special needs.
Every retard,
retard.
You meet as a different
person with different dreams
and desires just like you.
Retards. Okay? Yeah. Some
do like white bummer movies.
Some get married,
some have jobs live independently and yes,
they drive.
No,
it's not pleasurable to be retarded.
You sound dumb.
Mommy. Tina, I'm sorry,
but no, wait a minute.
Are you saying on this comedy show,
this is not serious show I sound stupid.
Well, that's weird. And
the email. Yeah. Uh,
some of my students fully understand
the world around them as well as their
struggle. I don't know about fully
and I don't think it's fully, uh,
they were retarded,
Babe. Whatever they go,
people think they don't know shit and
all they do is um, masturbate and drill.
Right. Shut the fuck up with this. Oh,
Sarah. Sarah is, she's got a point,
Sara. All right. Well,
retarded. I didn't, but we,
we, we knew that they had lives. We're
not [inaudible]. They don't have lives.
We did that. We did. Where
does it know they could drive?
That was the big surprise was the
drive thing. And that's all on me. I,
first of all, I thought that your
comment was insane. That like,
do they not know that they're retarded? I
wouldn't. I did. I genuinely didn't know.
I believe that you genuinely said it.
Yeah. I still thought it was crazy,
but my thing was I really
didn't know if they could drive.
I really didn't know
that. Well. Yeah, I know.
I'm saying like I'm volunteering
that she's saying that like, yeah,
some of them drive like in other words,
you're stupid for not knowing that.
I really didn't know that.
I asked genuinely I didn't think it was
possible that so either with that level
of visibility it came mental capacity,
which he needs some mental
capacity to drive that react.
Absolute reads signs,
whatever the fuck it is this a legit,
what about like junction?
You know what I mean?
Like where things come together and four
wheels and like, oh yeah, it's a lot.
I know the rules. I mean I thought
that that would be more complex.
Complicated for me.
I'm barely not retiring,
but the the question as to whether or
not they are aware that they are retired.
Of course there no to know. We'll hear me
out. Let's look at this philosophically.
If you are this thing and you don't know,
maybe you don't know another way of being
just because you are that way, does it?
It's just like the gays. It doesn't it.
It does a dog. No, it's consciousness.
As a dog consciousness that it's separate
from that being human is different.
I don't know. I feel like I want
to bail you out and an animal,
different consciousness. Retired persons,
different consciousness letting me,
I don't care. I really don't give a shit.
I don't care to fuck. No, not really.
Zero fucks given about what about
whatever. If somebody is upset that I,
I uh, you know, if I have a
genuine and telling you how come,
how come, why, why come? Why can't I be
curious about this? You can be curious.
You can be curious.
It's fun.
Oh, somebody says you cheating.
Cheating. Huh? Uh, I'm furious.
This person writes,
I am not going to take it any longer.
Christina put cheat ski.
Yeah.
Routinely cheats at would you
rather know stop and her husband,
Tom allows it because of
sexism and nepotism and Obama.
It is an outrage and a tragedy on
par with the worst crimes in history.
She's basically Pol Pot when the options
in would you rather are poor and skinny
or rich and fat.
You cannot say you'll choose
skinny and find a rich guy.
No, no, no option is skinny and poor.
So even if you did find a rich guy,
you would not be able to enjoy any of
his money or the trappings of his wealth.
He would remain in a shed in the
backyard like a proper poor person.
How dare you allow this cheating
to continue? How dare you.
I demand reparations.
Yours forever and love Bert Buczynski,
Lao. Bert. That's a, that's a really
good point. You made a good point.
Thank you for bringing that
to our attention. Yeah, you
do do that. You're like,
I'll just find this way through it.
Would you rather at the loophole, Yana,
I went to law school for two though,
because you're present.
You're like your skin, like this is your
life or this is your life, which life?
And you're like, well you do it this way.
There's always a work around in life,
don't you get it, Tom, that's
not, how would you rather works?
Do you think your honor would send you
to the hole for 30 days just through
pitching this idea and come
on. That's all. That's how,
that's how you play the game. You have
to find your work around another email.
Critical view.
These emails,
how much I suck.
Who's faking the email?
Hey Hitler,
I've known as Jesus Jeans says plenty of,
can I say something? Can I tell you
something? Because he never listens.
Tom Never listens to can I just say,
do you think this is the Midwestern mom
translation of, you know what I'm saying?
You feel me? Or you know what I mean?
Finished and done shorty. George PS,
chef John,
might as well be a member of the Wu Tang
clan because he ain't nothing to fuck
with. Wow. Still upset
about making fun to shoot.
Can I tell you why I tell you why I say,
can I say something right?
Because you just talk right over me.
You've done it this episode like
two or three times. Oh, come on.
I have to interject. Otherwise I
can't get my fucking thought in there.
You really feel that way. Hello. Then
why am I saying, can I say something?
Because it's always cause you
don't let me, you move on.
See like right now I'm talking to you
and you're looking at the soundboard.
Tell him, look at me. No, but I'm
still listening to you. No ma'am.
Can I say something?
Can I just say something?
The thing is we watch sesame
street and what is cookie monster?
Learn to listen with whole body.
Whole body, whole mine eyes,
eyes wide,
body relax and you don't do that for me.
Even right now.
You're fucking looking at the computer
and still listen to you and not fully,
not like cookie monster. Listen, why does
it have to be exactly that way? Can I do,
would you rather real quick? You
want to do it with your other, yeah,
go ahead and just go for it. It's simple.
It's not, it's not too complicated.
Okay.
Would you rather live in a courtyard
Marriott where you did where I did?
Yeah. It's like those for those
of you don't know what that is.
It's a Marriott that you can actually
like. It has a kitchenette bathroom,
you know, like kind of like living in
a, in a crummy apartment. Yeah. Okay.
That's your living situation.
Tiny communal pool made
service or it's an Rv.
You live like it like I did on
road rules, road rules, life, RV.
Now keep in mind the RV. Yes,
you, you can park in RV parks.
You can't really park an RV just anywhere.
Don't think you can.
And if you take a shit in that Rv, you
have to unload the sewage system in it.
But I think you could learn
that pretty quickly. Right.
But it still stinks and it cooks in
the summertime, the shit. I mean,
maybe now it's better, but back
in the 90s, that's how it was.
Um hmm. But so wait, what is it?
How long are we living in
each situation of your life?
So you're either living at the courtyard
Marriott or in the, in the RV. Yeah.
But it looks like with
the Rv you have mobility.
Yeah. Oh, okay. Well let's change it up.
Oh, so, so let's change it up. No, no, no.
I'm making the courtyard Marriott more,
more appealing.
You can live at any courtyard,
Marriott location. Oh, now as you know,
can you have one built just for you?
No, but I'm saying like if you go,
let's say you go, oh I can, I
want to live in a, you know,
New York City and they don't have
one. Can you say New York City? No,
it was to be an existing
location. Okay. And as you know,
the locations are generally across from
like a nice Chili's or maybe down the
street, a mile from our red lobster. Sure.
Generally not a sidewalk in front of it.
And so usually on a busy highway the views
are of parking lots, things like that.
Um, I think I would still
choose the RV. Okay.
Because you can move it, you can drive
it right. It's part of the appeal to me.
So I think I would,
I would get,
I would get comfortable,
I would learn how to dump my sewage
and maybe real stinky. I'm sure it is.
I'm sure it's terrible. Um, that's the
only thing I asked Brian Regan by the way,
when, cause he has a tour bus, I go really
nice tour bus. It's your first question.
Yeah. Go. So can I ask you, I go the
rules on tour buses is like no shit.
So like right. It's always
like, I was like, no shits.
You know you piss in here but you can't
shit in here. Can I go so isn't that,
he goes, well no I, I shit. And I said,
well he doesn't say he actually was like,
no I can't. I go, well so it doesn't, your
whole bus smelled like shit then. Yeah,
I think it was now cause it's like they
have new technology now where it's like
this grinding thing and it's
like a whole, he goes, yeah,
I wouldn't get one if I couldn't
take it down. He was like,
this is all you want to talk about.
Cause I kept talking.
Well it's fascinating because airplanes,
they have to unload the septic
tank to after every flight.
Anybody that tours that is like the, one
of the first things. It's always like,
hey, especially it was a group,
you know, a band touring or
friends. You're like, we are not
dumping here man. Yeah. Yeah. You can't,
you can't have five guys constantly
shitting on your tour bus for getting it.
I see.
Now here's the other thing with the Rv
Park that are the RV that you don't make
me not think about as a professional.
I've lived on one. You can't, like I said,
you need electricity to plug
into at night, so you're not,
you're not parking your
trailer necessarily in just
in front of any residential
street.
Cause someone will call the cops.
You have to go to RV parks to plug
in to get your amenity to shower,
you know? Yeah. Now RV parks
sometimes are not that nice. You're,
you're amongst special
different people. Yeah. And um,
some of them are nice and Australia,
like some of them were super nice.
Like there's one in Malibu
that overlooks the ocean.
It's like a million dollar RV park.
Elitist. Yeah. Oh of course. Yeah. Not La.
So anywhere that's not La, who knows what
the situation will be like, you know?
That's true. That's true. How do you feel
about tour bus? Would you do it? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So do you think you are
though the, can I say something?
Can I just say something Jay? Oh, let me
guess. Cause is there a super cut? No,
there's not. There's no, okay. Yeah.
Interesting that you need in your
preparation for today's shit on Christina
episode. There wasn't a super cut,
not a should ocracy and atmosphere is,
it sure feels like it.
People like my personality and Allison
is that she never seen episode.
You've just been really, you know, you,
I think you're a little angry then.
I left you this weekend
over nick.
That's just a little bit of
you right there. It's not me.
You know what I'm saying? You, you
know what I'm saying? But you know,
you know who the, you know, champ is, it's
a kid from Harvard. He's a hockey player.
Oh Tyler, thanks for being here. How about
the keys to the game and facing Duluth
tomorrow? Yeah, I think, uh, you know,
the main thing is just going to be
managing the environment. Obviously,
if we've got a great, uh,
Opportunity here and, you know,
a lot of fans and Tyler Moin
on everything, um, you know,
and just managing that and what's
been the key to this wall here and,
you know, to, uh, you know, to create
that kind of culture where, you know,
we hold each other accountable,
you know, and to a, you know,
really get up for big games.
And I think that that's been
something that we've been
able to draw from. And, um,
you know, like, like I said
before, we got, we've got a
great, uh, Opportunity here,
you know, and, you know, we know there
no weekend news, you know, but you know,
you know, to, uh, you know, you're
Latino, you know, this, you know, like,
you know, like right now, just trying to
give me an occasional major, I'm guessing,
you know. Yeah. We've, uh, we've, uh,
obviously I got a great opportunity here.
Oof. Wow. So we had an ivy league,
Ivy League, you know, that's a big,
that's a big step. We never had a
Harvard one. No, we haven't. That's a,
that's, that's quite a unique thing to
have a Harvard level, you know, champ.
Very special. Can I, you know
what I'm saying? Just say,
you know what I'm saying,
that uh, thanks to everybody that
downloaded, uh, mostly stories,
the album, Eh, you,
you may be number one on and
I got the physical copies.
I signed a bunch of them today and
they're at the, uh, in the store.
So if you want an autographed,
a hard copy of the album,
it has two bonus tracks.
I put that in the store.
It's in the store right now.
I also,
um,
went to recent or sign the
remaining glass and posters.
So if you want it to be glass and poster
and it's funny, it's autographed. The uh,
the rest of them I autograph.
The rest of you kindly offered me an
autographed copy of mostly stories.
Thank you for that. Yeah, I did.
I offered for that. Um, and,
and I keep getting asked, everyone
says vinyl. What about vinyl?
There is going to be a vinyl
release in June of mostly stories.
So if you're waiting for vinyl,
I'll announce it. A big thing then,
but it is going to be in June and that
will come with a little side little
present with it. Oh Hey,
do you want to hear my
new foreign voicemail?
Is there any way we could listen to
it? Uh, yeah, you can hear it set.
Tell me what your voicemail it is.
Let me just make sure they can't,
they can't transcribe it.
Apple. That's fine. That's
fine. The top one. The top one.
Two one, three number. Okay.
Yeah, I got a brand new,
it looks like I have a brand new, a silo
me cause we lost her a he's gone. Yeah.
Oh yes. That solid may finally
figured it out. I think so.
But now I've got a new one which is
kind of exciting and I hope it keeps up.
Yeah, I hope so too. Um, I should
have it here in a moment. People, uh,
someone weighed in here, I think my
at council weighed in on the pilot,
blowjob offer. Jesus, you had
your, you retained counsel,
um, to, to negotiate with me.
Right. So this is the email that
I think your counsel received.
The Kim Dear Mrs [inaudible].
This is the water champ personality
and I'm pretty much everything.
Champs representation.
We have picked up Mr Segura on a pro
bono basis because of said champion this
and such. Find that he is fully
deserving of everything he wishes.
Now down to brass tacks,
we counter propose since the main mommy
has to do something he doesn't wish to
do refrain from obtaining
his pilot license.
So should you in likeness after
all justice his eye for an eye.
All I am sure as I'm sure Mrs. Gross
sickened by the fact that he'll be missing
out on his license and the for 40 hours
of instruction we counter propose the
you must watch and listen to 40 hours
of vomiting and try to be completed no
later than one year time.
Furthermore,
you must listen and watch vomiting and
dry heaving for at least two hours per
year thereafter.
To counterbalance all the splendors that
Mr [inaudible] girl we missed by be not
becoming a pilot. Sincerely don't
frown white, Brown and associates
while your councils are really,
I got a stupid argument. Well,
let's see what your counsel replies
with. Now. Here's what I'm thinking.
You are in the midst of negotiating for
the blowjob pilot license and we know
that there's going to be a lot of back
and forth and no one's going to settle on
the first offer. I'm wondering if we
could throw this into the mix as well.
Introducing the model one service droid
from our limb robotics engineer to
perform the most intimate,
pleasurable human interaction
discreetly at a price you can afford.
Yeah. And this way you don't
have to do as much. Right.
Does she get to where the
hiking boots and the rain,
whatever you want to put her
in. I love that park. That
winter wonderland. Blowjob.
Why is she,
why the rain boots?
Because it's hard to give blow jobs out,
uh,
out of ladies after a long hike.
I think that cause right if you go like
let's go on his hike and camp and then
it's like, oh man, we just hiked all day
and be like, Hey, can I get that Bj now?
And she's pretty tired and pretty
dirty. I'd really like to, you know,
can we wait till we get back to
civilization? And you're like, oh,
it's a pitch all into the fucking excuse.
That camping fantasy is
top on the porn stuff.
But when you strip all that stuff
away, all you got is this. So you know,
not as central, it features a fully
adjustable body hiding in plain sight.
Disguise does a cushion
and model robot warrior,
it's designed to be assembled in seconds.
All it takes is a folded blanket over
the bottom. Oh yeah, there you go.
That's what outer clothing garment
of your choice to create a model.
So realistic, feel like another
human in the room with you. Boy,
that is the saddest thing I've ever seen.
How really? I thought it was so joyful.
Fingertip control allows speeds ranging
from gentle foreplay to a punishing 120
cycles per minute. But with enough
system latency to be safely stopped.
So you can say the soft flexible
entry give smooth access complete with
semi-hard teeth. Nice tongue anthro
contours are realistic experience.
Gosh, it seems like it's not funny.
This is, this is all we think about.
Many use their intellect to
create things to make them come.
That's how the Internet was developed.
It's just I need to come.
I need to come in.
It's pretty amazing.
All right,
and then turn disturbing the flow
of air unrestricted movement.
The exit tube can be covered
with a fingertip to the
exit to provide toe curling
suction on demand.
Oh, so you can, it's like hitting a
bong. You know, like a pipe. You know,
you just cover up the air there.
The up to 100% human hair is attached
securely flowing directly from inside the
model scale. This can be
washed shampooed, ironed, cut,
styled any way. Design plunging your
fingers through the thick, luxurious,
soft hair. Beautiful. Forget
hard plastic containers.
Vibrating balls are rings that
provides such a natural sensation.
Nothing can imitate that gentle rhythmic
caressing motion. The head on the chest.
It makes you sad a little bit
though. What are you talking about? I
mean it is the happiest all ever for how
many people are like fucking finally,
you know, I want them to focus on
what's the price tag? I mean that's,
that's got it costs like 10 grand.
That looks like it's expensive. Super,
very reasonable.
We didn't get to the real price.
My thinking is if you can pay for that,
why not just pay for an actual woman to
do that for you? That's a good point.
Yeah. I guess I said this thing,
you know you can just have it for,
you don't have to call again. Here's the
thing. It's like you can wash this hair.
First of all,
you know dudes aren't going to wash her
hair and they're not going to clean out
the mouth. He, that's the
problem. The real problem. Yeah.
They're going to nut in that thing
and then I'll be like, oh no,
it's growing mushrooms. Why
is it rotten? Yeah, it smells.
Oh,
he can't really trust men
with this sort of technology.
I feel like this is not good idea.
That smells is going to be horrible.
No. Here's the, here's the real, here's
what you need. A service. Really.
It smells bad. It's what I'm saying. Well,
here's a service that needs to happen.
There needs to be an app and you can
order the machine to be delivered and then
taken away. Oh, isn't it? And then you
leave it out front. Like in a hotel.
When you leave the, the takeout
with the dining services stuff,
just throwing done dot. Yeah. That's
the service disposable. One of these.
That's another, yeah. Disposable heads.
The head in the trash and then garbage
comes on Monday and they're like,
there's six female doll heads and the
trash with their mouths open eyes are uh,
and there's calm. Just drawing
it all over them. The solution.
But I had a crazy weekend. Jesus. Ooh.
Feel better though. I feel way better.
Right? That's the solution. Um,
there's no way to dudes are maintaining
that things. Hair and mouth. No, no, no.
Guys are casting real fucking
animals, man. Come on.
The guy that's going to do that.
You think he's a real neat freak,
real socialized person thinks
about stuff like that. Hell No.
Hell to the no, he's cutting up cats in
a basement somewhere. Oh yeah, for sure.
Um, so what does I wanted
to play for you? Oh,
you had an email to read reading them
it. No, you were going to read an email.
You said that you read an email and
we'll look for once in my life being an
asshole really paid off. And
I'll show you why. Tell me why.
My wonderful demeanor I've
saved lives as it says here,
Mommy, Tina saved my life.
Please. Wow. Yup. Yup.
My dearest mommy is
nothing but love t bonds,
but this email is about how my main money,
Christina saved my life.
I can't reference the
episode, but Christina made a
comment, then changed my life.
I'm paraphrasing and I'm far
too lazy to find the episode.
But a comment was made
that if you are 400 pounds,
you either need to get your
life or go for a world record.
At the time I heard this,
I was 406 pounds. Wow. Wow.
In the heat of the moment.
I hated her for the comment.
That opinion quickly changed
after a good night's sleep.
I couldn't shake her words and decided
for the first time in my life I was going
to make a positive decision.
I decided that I didn't want it to be
one of these fat fucks that needs to be
fork lifted out of their home after a
series of heart attacks and decided to
actually do something about it.
That morning I joined a
weight loss program for men.
Huge shout out to Harvey
Brooker in Toronto there.
Couldn't have done it without you started
taking my diet seriously and got off
my ass and started working out.
At the time of this email,
I am pleased to say that I am now down
100 pounds and pushing for 100 pounds
more. I send this email is simply thank
Christina for the inadvertent inadvertent
motivation to get my shit together.
She honestly extended my life by making
an off the cuff remark and is directly
responsible for improving my
quality of life. My more active,
confident and a straight up pussy slayer.
But my dog looks significantly bigger
and I can fuck for a straight three
minutes without breaking a sweat. There
you go. So thanks for the [inaudible].
Now see what's his name? Johnny.
Johnny congratulate. Thanks Johnny.
That's amazing. A hundred
pounds, dude, congratulations.
This is the Shit I've ever seen.
An episode.
That's the celebrate Christina
episode. Yeah, I mean, you
know, I sometimes I just,
even with drop pearls,
you know,
I would say because I help people,
I have the better personality
and definitely a personality
chant. Somebody Bros,
nothing but helping people right in
there is the real champ
breakdown. Oh, Jesus wasn't here.
You greedy mommies.
You both can be the chance of everything.
So I went and did a you as a favor and
broke it down and it listen to your
podcasts in the car and when I get carts
at food lion, so I got this shit. Okay.
BURP champ. This is Tom. Ron. This
is evident throughout the podcast.
He has variety volume and
that. Oh, so perfect pitch.
F A R t champ. Christina. Listen,
Tom had that one fart on the mic. He
did recently. That was immaculate,
but Mommy team, Tina seems to
have her farts down. Thank you.
Water Champ. Tom. Ron, I should know.
I have to explain this one. We know
he downs gallons of water every day.
Even Joe Rogan is a witness to his
water madness personality champ.
Christina, she just seems
Pfizer, Pfizer, Pfizer.
She just seems nicer. I don't
know. Fuck you. That's what
he wrote on. There you go.
I have nice glass and
champ. Christina, thank you.
I know this hasn't been brought up,
but come on.
Tina's always writing down notes is very
observant and which is a necessity for
glass and if I miss the championship,
please let me know and I will analyze the
evidence. Thanks for the show. Love you.
Mommy is keep it high and
motherfucking tight. Davis. No,
we never brought up the glass and
champ discussion, but I like it.
I'm definitely way more observant than
you. That's like, oh, I'm so observant.
No, you're not. You Miss
Everything. Literally everything.
You're not observant so much more
observant of my surroundings.
I know what's happening. You don't pick
up all, I pick up on stuff all the time.
I pick up on that.
Do you pick up on like a nail on the head?
But like you don't pick up on subtle cues.
You don't pick up on little
behavior nuances of voice,
of inflection of saying this and they
meant that the look that you don't pick up
on any of that.
Just like I care for a toddler a
lot and I pick up on what he needs.
He can't talk. I'd say
I'm very sensitive. Yeah.
Oh look at you.
All of a sudden I'm a stay at home dad
for two whole days and I know I'm the mom
champion. I don't think you're
the very observant person.
I'm so much more observant.
Oh, there he is. He's our guy.
He's a new food videos.
He trenched like pizza and ranch.
It's not bad.
It's good. He's fat are definitely,
sounds like he's in public.
There's like weird to make
this video in public. Right?
Well maybe that's the new thing, you know,
and he's letting it strip on his shirt.
It's, we're listening to king.
Asked ripper eat. By the way,
there's some fried chicken
definitely in a public setting
here that there's people around.
It's kind of weird that he would do this.
He's a stuffing food. I know. Honestly,
I'm not really into the eating videos as
much as I liked the farts in the burbs.
I don't like cause I feel like he's,
he's,
he's really interesting.
Fascinating.
Fascinating. Yeah. Jesus Christ.
Make an eye contact of the camp.
Is that a restaurant? Oh yeah.
He's in a restaurant. Oh, he
got like a back table. Yeah.
Good idea. Good thinking.
Even the buffet now. So he went to a
buffet so he's still making videos. Yeah.
God bless him. I miss him.
I know. I'm glad he's back.
It's really weird to see him not
wearing tidy whities. I know.
It's weird to see him out in public.
I didn't think he did that.
I thought he just stayed in his basement
all the time. Just farted on stuff. Yeah.
Barter on credenzas and such that I feel
like that's like old now. That's just,
it's not the same anymore. Well
evolved. He's an artist. He changes.
Can't expect him to stay
the same. Somebody wrote,
thanks for making me dream.
I am pleased to inform you that for the
first time in my entire life I had a
dream about taking a shit and
it's all. Thanks you. Oh Wow.
Listening to episode three 92 on a long,
late car ride home last night I got home,
I probably fell asleep and had a very
involved dream in which I was a young,
I was in a yoga class
and had to make Brown.
The toilet was in the middle
of the class for some reason,
and not only did the instructor
call my attention to my shitting,
but I was so embarrassed that I went to
wipe with my balled up tp and absolutely
got shit on my hand.
I've been a lifelong toilet
paper water up until today.
You've gotten into my psyche inception
style and now I feel I can finally get my
life. Thanks jeans, Kaitlin. Wow. I
wasn't even expecting that to be a lady.
No, me neither. That was lady. Oh
yeah. Or maybe it means Katelyn.
Maybe it's the Caitlyn.
Maybe could be,
which is obviously still
a a lady. I didn't mean to
suggest anything. Oh my God.
Save the Heysel offended. Please,
please save the hate mail.
What's your Pronoun of what's Your
Pronoun? Um, okay. Anything else Jean? Um,
no thanks for whoever came out to see me.
And um,
thank you to those who will come out to
see absolutely a go to [inaudible] dot
com to get tickets to
see Christina Thompson,
[inaudible] dot com for my live
dates. Uh, also my store is there.
If you want to pick up a,
anything I mentioned there's some super
excited I might even listen to. Uh,
is it mostly stories you sent this
out? I have two bonus tracks. Really?
So there's, there's a material.
Can you see what they're about?
I recorded them in Chicago when I
did the Chicago shows. Where Chicago.
And what did they, uh, beginning give
me just one is the follow up to that.
So in the special, I talk
about meeting Mike Tyson. Yeah.
And people always gave me,
she would email me what happened next.
So I tell the followup,
oh, that's fat. That's wonderful.
You should have said that earlier.
That's exciting. So you
give, give kind of the,
the insider scoop on of what
happened next, the whole thing. Yeah,
because I am the special with
the phone hanging up and they're
like, well, what happened next?
And I tell the story. Okay. And then
the other thing is I talk about, um,
I talk about making a murderer. The uh,
your life story. Yeah. The, the Netflix
show. Very cool. Well, that's
exciting. Very exciting.
Yeah.
Uh,
so Tom square.com go to the store or
you can download the album if you want.
Or Lord streaming, I dunno, however
you do it. Um, the glass and poster,
your mom's house, podcast.com. Please
don't forget to check that out.
Amazon, please do your shopping using
our banner. Go to your mom's house,
podcast.com. Click on the banner
at the bottom of the homepage.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
As always, I remind people that
there is youtube, uh, of this.
If you want to watch your show, people
seem to not know that for some reason. Um,
and I'm always going to solicit that you
write a review of the show on iTunes.
So if you don't mind,
just write a five star review of the show,
only five and jeans it up.
Make some he raps about
it. Check out this deep route.
You, if you're so inclined.
I actually am very nice on that show
and help people with their lives,
how people get their lives, even with a
sour personality. She's doing good work.
All right. Uh, thanks for listening.
We'll see you next week. Here is
champion of the wall by Ramsay Mcqueen,
your
mom's house
champion
champion.